do y'all want to watch me fail my
driver's test here we go
I am 27 years old grew up in Brooklyn
and I do not have my driver's license I
am 27 years old I was born in the state
of Texas and I do not have a driver's
license I'm from India and I have never
driven a car I am 30 years old I'm from
Texas originally or I have a permit I'm
29 years old originally from the Bronx
living in Harlem now and I do not have a
driver's license
[Music]
you're making a left turn from a two-way
street and into a one-way street when
you have completed the turn your car
should be from a two-way street into a
one-way street i what I picture if
you're turning to a one-way street there
isn't a left or right lane so I think
that eliminates the last two this is a
two-way street
great that's two lanes they're making a
left turn maybe I shouldn't get my
license I'm gonna say in the left lane
of the street when two vehicles enter an
intersection from different highways at
the same speed which vehicle must yield
the right-of-way
oh god it's either to your left or your
right I don't know if they've ever been
in the car that picked that you're not
supposed to signal somebody on like
you're supposed to go cuz then if they
get in an accident was your fault I
think it's the vehicle and you're right
I'm guessing I'm gonna see a vehicle on
the left because I have no idea and
that's like the first option then what
does a slow-moving vehicle emblem look
like they don't even show pictures they
just have words
eeny meeny miny moe I feel like I'm in
like minesweeper where every single
square could just be the de my demise I
don't know maybe it's the triangular are
in town that's just like I guess I'm
gonna go with triangular Orange sign
assuming that the street is leveled what
should you do after you have finished
parallel parking and space between two
other cars I just like think of parallel
parking and I know like this is wrong is
like going in but I think of like this
big suburban malls and when the cars are
like parked next to each other I
straight oh gosh and turn the wheels in
some way and I don't know which way told
you parallel parking is not my thing I
don't love this and I do remember that
if you park on a downhill slope parallel
park you have to turn your wheels
even though I didn't pass the parallel
parking part of my road test I know this
part to be true straighten your wheels
and leave the room between us on a road
which has no sidewalks a pedestrian
should walk on me I want to say oncoming
traffic the side of the road where the
traffic is moving because that's also
where cars should go not you don't do
you face oncoming traffic so you can see
it someone told me you should face the
oncoming traffic so you can see a car
about to hit you I'd say this side of
the road facing oncoming traffic
I think facing oncoming traffic you
definitely don't want cars whizzing from
behind you so probably would want to see
what's going on in front of you drivers
left arm and hander extended downward
that's a chill drive with this hand
signal means that the driver plans to so
I've seen drivers do this and I didn't
know it was a thing I just thought they
were like hanging out being cool in
their car I'm gonna go with it turn left
similar to how it is and basically I
think they're stopping I think that
means oh my god I've asked I bet I have
failed I wouldn't use the word excited
I'm rather relieved but I think if you
just like use your common sense and if
you've been in a car like a few times in
your life I think you're gonna be fine I
don't want to make any promises but I
think after today I'm gonna go out there
and at least try to get a driver's
license I am bad at driving and probably
bad at questions about driving so I will
continue
driving hell catch me on your roads in
2018 baby
Clark skin is dry rising